son las nueve de la noche en la plaza de
la república en parís y este hombre se
rehúsa a dejar su tienda mientras la
mayoría no se resistió al avance de la
policía él fue uno de varios migrantes
que fueron desalojados por la fuerza
después de apoderarse de sus tiendas las
fuerzas de seguridad usaron gas
lacrimógeno para dispersar a los
refugiados y a quienes nos apoyan
no tenemos dónde vivir donde dormir lo
necesitamos con este clima el invierno
está llegando está haciendo más frío y
necesitamos un lugar donde dormir
benítez alberto flip más temprano en la
noche voluntarios ayudaron a alrededor
de 500 migrantes a instalarse en la
icónica plaza pública luego de que su
campamento al norte de la capital fuera
de evacuado la semana pasada necesitamos
frenar este círculo vicioso de
campamentos que aparecen son evacuados a
menudo con violencia y vuelven a
aparecer sus ojos forma
las imágenes de la violencia de los
oficiales de policía se esparcieron
rápidamente en las redes sociales
incluyendo un vídeo de un periodista en
el suelo luego de haber sido derribado
el ministro del interior- geralda
hermana calificó las escenas de
impactantes y ordene un reporte policial
sobre el desalojo esto ocurre luego de
que el gobierno aprobara una enmienda
que restringiría la publicación de
rostros de oficiales de policía los
sindicatos aseguran que eso podría
darles 'luz verde' a los policías para
evitar que los periodistas documente en
abusos